大家好，欢迎收听ARC，这是一档探索人工证的播客。无论您是关注AI产品设计、探索前沿技术，还是专注于投资布局，这里都将为您提供深度动差与前瞻性观点。感谢收听，让我们开始今天的精彩节目吧。
大家好，欢迎收听ARC，我是普通。
大家好，我是Leo，我们两个今天主动给大家来录这一期播客。
今天想跟Leo聊一聊在硅谷AI的一线体感，是从这个楼内高潮还是变成一种背景音。
然后Leo，你在硅谷技术人面对AI的变化是变得更冷静还是更疲惫？
对，我自己觉得其实大家对从1923年到现在三年半的时间，其实大家足够会变得更为冷静一些，
更准确说，刚刚提到的我们把AI更做的是做为自己日常的生活工作的一个背景。
希望大家已经默认，就是AI可以帮我做很多事情，而如果使用AI，其实是大家现在最关心的。
对，这是我其实想说的。
再一个说，回过这三年的一个历史说，之前大家可能对于刚出来模型这个点会变得非常的兴奋，
即不可带的把AI模型签了到自己的一些工作流，包括一些创业者，周围有很多创业者。
但是现在大家其实已经默认AI可以帮你做一些基础性的一些工作，帮你去生活上变得更加便利。
所以大家现在可能更兴奋的点在于模型，除了它本身的这些本身模型之外，
它给我们生活到底带来了怎样的便利，它给我们工作上又会降本增效。
那扩大到一个high-level的角度上来说，比如作为一个可以管理一些人的一些团队或者是一个start-up，
所以他们更重要的是关注，就是AI如何去服务于它现有的一些work flow，如何服务于它现有的一些产品的feature。
我觉得这一点其实还是蛮不同的。
大家从一个刚接触AI的一个性能的状态到逐渐适应了AI成为自己生活无踪的一部分，
从而逐步增强自己对AI的一个适用的能力。
对，我自己的感觉也是AI慢慢的从一个巨大的器官一个demo出来，大家都会觉得what's up，什么都变了，世界都变了，
但现在就是模型发布，大家动作又变成了看一眼benchmark，然后API再介入一下，
看看能不能嵌套到自己的work flow里面，就继续开始搬砖了，就慢慢的变成了日常，也不是说它不重要了。
再加上之前，大家其实对于AI的者和已经陷入到自己的工作流了，尤其是这种开发者规模更多的是开发者的角度，
其实加一个API到自己的工作流当中并不是一件难的事情，
包括现在的中型和大型的规模公司，它其实已经鼓励的要去使用了，
给大家一定的每天有一个使用的一个budget，你在这个budget可以任意去使用。
在这种前提下，其实你新的模型发布了，我其实并不需要就挨个去看的matrix到底有多么的好，
我其实就简单的切换一下你的模型的API就可以了。
如果这个模型可以让我跑得更快，可以让我得到更好的结果，并且它没有大幅增加我的一个成本，
我们就会切换到最好的模型去使用，但如果这个模型变得又贵，然后性能没有很大的提升的话，
我们还是维持原来的这个模型，它要足够cover，就是绝大部分的故障内容，那就够了。
所以说我们现在因为对于AI的者和能力现在来说不要成熟，就关注benchmark本身来说并不是一个重要的点，
而是在于我们实际使用的体感如何。
对，那你觉得模型之间的差距它是在慢慢的被拉大了，还是说是在缩小了？
我觉得这三年来说，从硅谷这几家做大模型的角度上来说，是一个非常有意思的过程。
其实一开始大家对于能做出来这个大模型，并且有一定的实际效果的这些顶尖的模型公司也opened out 为力的一步慢的随后，
所以他们只是这世界上只有那一小撮人当时做出来这样的模型。
所以说那个时候的模型，反而它的功能更一样，大家都想实现那些基本的功能，
达到一个基本的一个benchmark，让大家可以使用。
反而在中间这两年，其实大家各自发展的风筝还挺多一样，比如说像DeepMild，
它肯定更注重自己的一个多摩坦。
之前的马斯克的XA，它更注重说如果服务于它自己现在的一些公司，
还有其实推特这种产品。
Zorpeak就慢慢摸索出来一个coding 路。
opening 还是比较优越，现在它是一个网组。
所以在这个过程中，它的模型的expertise是产生一定的分化。
但是最近就这半年来看，我觉得大家又聚伦到了coding 这个部分。
现在无论是OpenLine，它有codex，
然后XAi 收购了cursor，它就是想凹移这个coding。
然后Gemna 我听那个相机说，他们也是想凹移这个，
就是比较开始把自己的一个工作业绩主机转到这个coding 上。
所以现在大家又开始收敛了这个方向。
我也在蛮多的这种产品上看到，
以前的vibecoding，现在已经慢慢的往coding agent 上去转变了。
其实这里有一点非常想和你沟通或者聊一下的话题，
就是之前会觉得模型和模型之间的差距，
所以会让普通用户之间有一个gap，
相当于用更好的模型的产品也会更好，
但随着这个模型之间的差距在拉近，
那普通用户或者说应用层之间的这个差距，
是不是也在快速的被拉平。
其实我觉得有一个根本的一个不一样的点，
现在的创业者，现在的一些传媒开发者，
他对于模型的sense比两年和三年之间要更强。
他其实是会知道什么样的模型，
更适合自己的产品的feature图片，
或者说一些模型广告这种声称，
但自然而然就会选择证明，
如果你是叫做这种工作流的图笔业务的，
可能按锁要费claw coefficient的最好的选项，
就是他一定是经过5分测试选择有这样的一个模型，
去费得到他自己的产品和工作流上面。
至于说刚才的一个问题，
其实我认为他怎么会出现这种情况，
模型的能力再次的驱同，
加上应用层的一些engineering的work，
他最终存在的效果可能是一个驱同的，
但这个过程当中其实是涉及到，
他的engineering work到底是有多少，
他需要加百分之多少的力量，
在这个模型AP上，
打到相同的一个结果。
再一个就是说他的成本，
每个模型他的cost是不一样的，
大家都想用最牛逼的模型，
但最牛逼的模型也意味着他的cost是最大的，
所以也是要根据自己的产品所需要的cost，
规限的这种budget的范围之内，
选择最佳的allows。
再一个就是一个open source，
其实open source在很多时候他其实比较便宜的，
因为他不需要给模型厂商去支付，
API的这个钱，
对他只需要是我有一个数据中心，
有时候我有一个这卡，
我只要可以把这个模型给部署上去了，
部署上去之后他可以软伺的钱，
就是这个卡做消耗的这个钱，
所以我觉得这个东西一切都是基于你自己的产品，
你的团队就考虑了。
是，看起来慢慢的从之前的CGX用不同的模型，
开始往怎么去做降本，
像我开始卷在模型厂的这个成本上去做一些变化？
对，像一开始，
像在GDP刚出来的那半年到一年的时间，
我认为每个媒体里面大部分的创业者，
默认就是用open IDAPI，
但是现在不一样，
对，当然是难度选择的，
根据你的产品的性能来选择，
甚至有很多硅谷这边会选择用，
比如说像fairworks，
或者说这种模型部署公司，
这模型部署公司他们部署的是中国的open source的帽子，
原本有辣辣现在不做了，
所以说很多时候他们会不准备需要支援他们的模型，
里面还有TMI的那些很多的口领做的能力也很强，
所以他们会通过跟部署的这种公司，
像fairworks,。
然后从而也调用这些open source的帽子，
就蛮多不一样的一些图件的，
对，你说到这个调用国内的模型，
其实还有点蛮有意思的，
在看那个open route上，
可以看到不同的这个模型调用token的排行榜，
现在基本上像国内的小米的，
或者是支援的以及kimi的，
他们在调用上已经慢慢的往上升，
而且整个token的占用量已经达到50%，
那我也想说，
硅谷那边或者你身边是否真的有大量的这种工程师，
确实在用国内模型，
卧山模型，
在解决一些工程问题，对的。
有一个很简单的，
之前大家都是知道他是用sorefaker，
但是因为sorefaker所谓的叫背刺，
也不多说背刺，
就是说，
本来柯测是给他引入流量入口的，
但是当时sorefaker已经意识到，
就是coding可以转很多钱，
所以他们自己做了自己的crown code，
但相当于是跟原来的一个customer，
是有一个不太好的一个别扭的感觉，
所以后来柯测意识到，
我们自己还是要有自己的模型，
所以他们其实是在用kimi的，
一个coding的一个模型做一些额外的训练，
就是一个非常好的非常大的例子，
就是现在其实柯测有很多的一些常识，
就在模型的post training，
但是限于他本身这个公司，
他并不是一个research起家的那个公司，
所以我猜这是一个原因，
他的马斯克的公司去合并，
也相当于马斯克的公司，
可以提供他很多的一些算力和运算，
prison那边可以提供他很多的一些数据，
这两家合作，
应该可能会做出一个非常不错的一个collision，
这样柯测AI就可以说，
是不再depend on这个sorefaker那边，
那你觉得kostler最后以600亿的身价。
mine给grop是一个好的声音吗？
我觉得找马斯克之后，
认为他是好声音的，就是好声音的。
可以的。
好，我们再来聊一聊，
硅谷这边，
你们是怎么在生活上，
或者工作中去用AI这一块，
像你现在生活日常工作中是怎么用AI的，
他已经是工作流的一部分了吗？
我觉得是的，
基本上来说，
我现在的所有的代码，
所有的一些文案的一些summarize，
包括一些有更好的report，
我都是用AI去做的，
而且,
现在我是自己发掘到，
我还有周围的人，
如果哪一天碰到了cloud的发言非常慢，
我们就自然而然就说，
今天大家一起摸鱼，
没法接受。
我们其实，
对，已经高度依赖AI了其实，
因为在你人类的一个非常不好的一个本性，
就是当你，
当我们发现了一条捷径，
做到好的结果的时候，
那那个捷径就是唯一的路，
That's it!。
就是说，
当你找到一个快速的捷径，
可以让你产生一些，
受到非常好的结果的时候，
你就会认为，
那个就是你现在唯一需要的，
当这个捷径被封住了那一天，
你会觉得我根本不自在，
我要重新干很多事情，
我现在懒得干，
反正这个捷径，
明天就会打同的，
我等到明天再干。
是这样的，
如果没有AI，
感觉就不会工作了。
对，我除了自己的工作，
包括我最外的，
其他一些，
比如说，
像投资，
这些生活机票查询，
我都是用，
比如说，
拆GDP,
我觉得他想来说，
更好用一点，
我会用拆GDP，
帮我去做很多的一些事情，
我分析很多事情，
有些不太懂的一些，
信用卡，投资理财的东西，
我也让你拆GDP帮我去借大，
所以我总而言之，
AI已经在我生活中，
有一个非常重要的一个位置。
我看最近拆GDP，
也在美国地区，
推出了一系列的，
新的金融服务，
比如说，
可以管理你所有的，
股票账户，
接入盈透，
还有接入你的，
各种银行账户，
去帮你做投资理财管理，
我还蛮想体验这一功能，
但是他目前只对美国用户开放，
对,
不然你有没有用过，
这个产品，
或者用过这个服务？
我暂时不太选择，
有的时候，
我反而觉得，
影响了我投资理财的，
一个点是在于，
信息量过多，
而不是信息量过少。
哦，这个可以展开讲讲吗？
这个其实是在于，
现在市场的整个情绪，
因为,
大家也知道美股，
的情绪还是比较高涨，
虽然最近跌了一点，
但是,
整体的势头还是比较丰富，
它其实会，
靠大很多，
倒身,
危险的一些点，
它会把很多危险的点，
给覆盖掉，
大家只愿意看到自己，
想看到的，
一些增长，
潜力非常大的点，
我觉得这个点，
其实是，
在我投资的时候，
会,
让我觉得非常担心的，
因为牛市，
大家看什么都是牛市，
所以说，
我有的时候，
会需要，
从这些信息当中，
签选出来，
我认为，
比较有，
帮助我去做判断的，
那,
信息越多，
我其实越难去签选，
信息少一些，
我觉得还像，
来说是比较好，
容易去签选，
对，明白，
像,
再具体一点，
比如说，
从,
最近长得比较好的，
几只骨像，
美光之类的，
那，技术人，
会不会因为，
更懂技术方，
而对这些，
AI趋势,
更加谨慎，
就从,
我们直观一点，
从你的这仓里去看，
这种,
AI相关的，
趋势的股票，
会在你的池仓里，
大概占多大比例？
现在的，
来说,
AI池仓,
还是在我，
本身的池仓当中，
还是比较大比例的，
怎么说，
当然我的股票，
总的仓位来算，
还是七大，
科技股，
它的仓位是最重，
如果加起来，
剩下的，
比如说，
能有百分之，
差不多百分之三十，
到四十，
直接,
是现在所有的，
AI相关的股票，
包括,
New Cloud,。
芯片,
包括,
所谓的，
很多的一些，
基建设施，
AI敞火的一些，
我,
回味你刚才的问题，
就是,
会不会变得，
我认为投资，
如果是，
你是一个，
相对来说，
比较成熟的投资者，
不是那种，
刚进股市那种小白，
或者是指头大排，
也不看别的，
那种,
投资者，
我认为投资可能，
更多的反应的，
第一个就是，
你对这个行业的理解，
第二个就是，
你本身的性格，
我觉得，
我并不是，
很谨慎，
我,
永远是投我自己懂的，
可能,
其实在某些行业，
我刚投的时候，
别人会认为，
这是一个，
不太看好的行业，
大家会认为，
我们已经有了，
Microsoft,。
我们已经有了IWS，
我们还有了Aurocone，
我们为什么还需要，
老四，老五，老六，老七，
老八，老九，老十，
但是它就是需要，
所以这个是，
像你自己去分析的，
并不是因为，
我在AI这个行业，
我就,
怎样,
或者我不在AI这个行业，
我就怎样，
其实是，
你自己的投资的风格，
去决定了，
你是否投资家的公司，
理解的，
那,
比如你刚刚说，
你还是会更多的，
关注在这个，
七公子，
这几个股票里面，
其实这七家公司，
它的策略，
对AI的策略，
是不一样的，
有些会更看重，
模型能力，
有的是，
更重分发，
或者生态，
以及产品落地，
在这一块，
你有什么偏好吗？
或者是，
影影的风格，
你会更喜欢，
是偏技术型的，
还是偏市场型的？
其实,
我可以简单说一下，
这些公司，
它大致对AI的一个策略，
我,
从各方面的一些交流，
比如说，
做的最好的，
这几家公司，
毕竟是Google，
毕竟有Gemma来这个模型，
我说,
就Google这个公司，
它,
在做Gemma来的时候，
它其实是一个，
非常了不起的一个过程，
因为,
据我了解，
大公司做AI模型，
这个progress的时候，
它永远是想的是，
我做完这个模型，
能不能，
为了我自己的产品，
做了服务，
所以他们会，
更注重工程化，
而不是一开始的，
Research的同路，
但Google,。
也许Deepman的，
他们在早期，
能把Gemma来，
2.5当时,
做的那么好的，
一个重要的原因，
其实是在于Deepman，
他的lead,
他能,
承受得住，
外界对他的质疑，
因为,
当时,
大家都觉得Google，
Google的search,。
会被Open ad,。
流量所分割，
他们的模型，
也没有那么的强，
是吧,
他们还有什么样的，
这种优势，
但是那那段时间，
他们就忍住这个压力，
我就专心去做模型，
从而把Gemma的能力，
打到了，
当时有的事，
也是超过材质疑，
我就是一个，
非常好的Quality，
当他们做出来，
一个成熟的，
好用的模型的时候，
再考虑下，
下放到他们所有的，
产品,
比如说，
他们下放到了像，
Pixel,
他有很多的一些，
模型的一些support，
Pixel手机,。
变得更加的，
智能化，
AI,
再的就是他们的一些，
啊,
广告啊，
Doc,
然后一些Gmail，
他们都加入了，
自己的AI，
甚至是YouTube，
对吧,
所以说，
我觉得他们这公司，
整个做AI的这个流程，
我自己是蛮，
欣赏的，
就是要做好，
放的,
放的Mental的一些能力，
然后再去，
考虑具体的产品，
而谷歌也是，
我当时投入的时候，
是在他最低谷，
就是一百四到一百六的时候，
去,
勇敢的加槽呢，
因为我认为，
谷歌是没有道理他，
不受益于AI这个时代的，
他有TPU,
他有自己的模型，
当时模型，
其实性能不错了，
但是远没有现在那么好，
但是我看到他们公司，
这个Potential,。
这个潜力，
然后再一个就是，
他们有自己的一些产品，
嗯,
所以我觉得谷歌是，
一个非常棒的，
一个,
一个leads吧，
然后第二个呢，
可能,
和AWS,
就是Amazon,。
他们其实更多的是，
坚持在，
原有的业务之上呢，
他们有各自的云，
可以通过云，
来去赚钱，
再一个就是，
他们分别投资，
这几年呢，
也可以通过投资，
包括对，
模型的一些，
所有权，
来,
在未来，
取得不错的一个手艺，
再一个就是，
MetaMeta,。
他还是，
注重如何将，
自己年的那个Avocado，
去,
呃,
作用在他们自己的，
广告业务当中，
嗯,
然后Apple,。
就是更注重，
是AMDWS,
他更注重的是，
让AI服务于，
他的,
具体的DWS，
像MacBook,。
像我们的Apple，
像Apple一样，
对,
除了这几家来说，
我自己，
当然是，
最美尔这个，
Google的,。
第二名还是，
英伟达，
毕竟是，
所有公司的一个接触，
如果,
有一天英伟达不行呢，
AI这个,
我们也不用讲，
我自己也买了，
不少英伟达的股票，
对,
感觉,
就可以永远相信老红，
不仅相信老红，
更多的，
还是相信，
GPU的这个能力，
还有Scale的这个能力，
它,
其实是，
甚至是TPU，
在非常短的时间内，
很难去，
实现的一个量，
对,
现在的TPU，
大家不是在考虑它，
好保佑了，
而是,
考虑它的量太少，
现在其实，
硅谷,
很多人，
虽然,
招聘的时候说，
Jax,
是一个，
one of the requirements,。
但是,
实际TPU,
使用的，
中大型的公司，
非常少，
大部分公司，
还要占着TPU，
对,
而且我看，
国内现在对TPU，
这一块的热度，
在上升，
像B300,
最近可以看到，
国内头部的两家公司，
在抢购这一块，
还是花不了钱的，
我看,
6月初,
他们还是，
以600多万，
去买了B300，
但是,
到前两天，
就25号的时候，
这个,
已经涨价到1000万了，
所以,
可以看到，
在抢TPU资源这一块，
大家,
无论是国内，
还是国外的公司，
都投入了，
大量的，
资金在这一部分，
那我们，
再来,
聊一聊，
这一块，
就,
你观察到的，
现在硅谷的，
AI创业者，
大家现在在做什么，
还在讲，
AI改变,
世界这种，
比较宏大的趋势，
还是也慢慢的，
开始务实的，
在具体的，
找倡警，
找客户，
和找付费的，
连维,
对,
我可以简单说一下，
这两年，
其实,
你对于我看到，
可能会有很多的，
跟我看到的是非一样的，
通常,
我的本质工资也不失踪，
OK,
其实,
在一开始的时候，
点是,
不仅是JPT的模型，
更火的一点，
是JPT Store,。
之后,
一年多的时间，
SWP出来跟MCP，
现在一开始，
大家,
非常早起的创业者，
我只说是，
从Application,。
从名声的，
来说,
2B或者2C,
大家当时，
其实很多人，
是做个Rapper，
就用API的模型，
简单做一个，
小小的功能，
就做成一个Startup，
但是,
现在,
我非常相信，
已经证伪了，
这些是行不通，
原因是因为，
Foundation的矛盾,。
在逐渐变强，
所以,
这就迫使了，
非常多的一些创业者，
现在要抓紧时间，
去意识到他们的优势，
尤其在一些Vertical的方向，
就他们在做的，
一些Vertical的方向，
首先,
第一点的前提，
这个成立的，
第一点前提，
就说,
这些模型公司，
它其实，
是很难去做，
大部分的Vertical，
我觉得，
这一点是非常重要的一个点，
其实说，
现在,
大公司都Focus在Coding上，
但是Coding,。
它并不是一个Vertical，
我认为，
Coding的能力，
更多的是，
一个Generic的功能，
比如说，
对于,
你的任务的理解，
任务的规划，
每一步规划，
你所调用的那个Call，
最终的一个整合能力，
还有,
做完整合能力，
还要加一个Unit Test，
Verify你,。
整个的Coding的功能，
是不够厉害，
如果一个模型，
它的Generic capability,。
不强的话，
它的Coding能力，一定不强，
所以,
大家可能，
现在做AI Agent，
Focus在这种Vertical,。
Whatever it is to be,。
还是to see,。
那这个时候，
就需要你在这个行业，
有一个Dominion Knowledge,。
这个Dominion Knowledge,。
就是取决于，
你真正是，
决定了你这个AI Agent的，
是否,
跟这个行业的Working Flow，
是相匹配，
我觉得，
这一点是蛮重要的，
第二点，
就是在于，
你是否能，
很好的Source，
你的客户权利，
你的图币业务的，
这种开发者，
他其实是要快速的，
有一个效果的能力，
如何跟你的客户，
进行一个共同交流，
如何快速，
跟进一个客户的要求，
去给代你的产品，
图币,
图币业务，
我觉得，
现在是表现的，
我觉得图币业务，
可以过后再聊，
图币业务，
是另外一个，
表达的一个问题，
所以我觉得，
现在,
大家对于，
自己的创业的方向，
我觉得，
是,
培养模型本身，
更重要的，
还是要回归到，
你的产品，
设计的一个逻辑，
它甚至就是一个，
Whatever,。
互联网时代，
还是任何一个时代，
你产品最终能做的好，
其实就在于，
你是否抓住国心要求，
是否在于你的团队，
够辞壮的去support，
这种,
不断接待的这种feature，
然后,
适配到你的用户上，
其实这个观点，
我认为，
自始至终都没有变过，
只不过，
在早期的时候，
因为模型的一些，
经验的update，
可以让很多人，
去忽略这一点，
他们只是想说，
我根据这个，
来做一个小app，
就有一个不错的start-up，
投资人愿意投嫌，
但是没够多久，
其实这件事，
你就被证伪了，
它就是做不通，
所以还是得从，
真实的需求去出发，
而不是说，
是资本背起来的一些，
去世,
就造成那种，
很繁荣的假象，
还有一点，
其实也蛮想，
跟你探讨一下，
因为国内其实，
最近很火的一个概念，
叫OPC,
一人公司，
这个概念，
在微股那边，
有看到这种case吗？
其实有呢，
一看一些，
融资比较多的，
这种,
融资,
还像情况不错的，
这种verlic layout,。
他们出使团队，
大部分都比较少，
其实他也，
相当于是几人，
就创立了一个，
固执的，
打几千万美金的，
这样的一个start-up，
其实就是蛮多的，
但是回归我，
刚才说的那种点，
还是最重要的是，
你是否了解，
以这个，
留质用户，
如果只是想，
自己做，
做一个产品，
自己自主，
也要有一点用户，
或者说，
只是high-five,。
或者一个体验，
那不在我刚才说的范围之内，
但如果真的是，
要去融资，
就把它做大做强，
还是核心需求比较重要，
所谓的一人公司，
无非就是说，
有很多的事情，
为呀,
可以帮你代，
但是,
还有就是，
Foundation Model,。
就是这个，
这些公司，
其实,
我们就用Foundation Model,。
来代替，
他们毕竟，
他们判断的Vertical东西，
还是没有，
这个时候，
如果你团队当中，
有,
相关的一些knowledge，
相关的一些人卖资源，
或者是你，
本身就有，
那我觉得，
一人公司，
还是蛮靠谱的，
但如果没有，
你还是要补全这个概念，
那说到这一点，
其实,
蛮多的，
产严,
同学,
他自身，
对这个，
技术的know-how，
还是有比较了解，
但是，相对，
这些knowledge,。
或者是，
怎么去把，
这些,
还是需要，
补弃这个短板，
那对于，
这些同学，
可能后续也想，
出来创业，
你有什么建议吗？
就是,
他们怎么在，
现在日常的工作中，
去积累这些knowledge？
你说的是，
具体的Dominion Knowledge,。
还是说，
如何成立一个start-up，
相关的？
就是一些Dominion Knowledge,。
对,
因为这些，
这些积累，
你才可以说，
在后面出来创业的时候，
有一个更好的，
业务,
方向吗？
OK,
我觉得，
有一个点，
自己为什么要，
做整方向？
本身来说，
你不是，
这个行业的，
专业人才，
那你为什么要，
做这个方向？
如果你没有一个，
straw motivation,。
那我建议，
还是不要做，
对,
就像我对某些行业，
我就是不感兴趣，
但我知道，
可能某行业，
存在,
赚钱的机会，
那就取决于，
我到时候，
是否有，
这个很惨的 motivation，
去赚钱，
如果没有，
我真的，
不会去做这个行业，
我就是不感兴趣，
我也不是很懂这个行业，
我的 motivation,。
去做这个行业，
你确实是想，
做一些改变，
但是你没有，
是相关脑里生的，
你就跟，
另外一个有，
像我脑里只的人，
去想办法去合作，
我相信，
AI,
可以帮你学习得更快，
但是,
每个行业，
它潜在的一些，
资源的积累，
AI,
是帮助不了你的，
甚至说，
即使是你聪明，
你也不可能，
达到很多人，
几十年的一个积累，
你要去跟它，
比一些，
软性的一些，
你很难去比，
一个靠谱的人，
去合作，
我觉得也是，
一个非常好的，
一个方式，
那像,
其实我们可以看到，
现在蛮多，
像YC,
最近也公布了，
它最新一年的，
一些头的项目，
比如说，
有一些coding agent,。
AI in broad,。
或者是，
教授客服发掘，
这些具体的，
常境里面，
很多产品，
都是慢慢的，
落实到具体了，
你能从，
切身的感受到，
这些真正火热的，
AI创业方向，
是有哪些？
我其实，
已经有两次，
就YC-Batch的,。
整体的，
质量不是很好，
我自我感觉，
现在比较火的，
其实还是，
刚才我说的，
一个Vertical AI,。
真的其实，
不缺,
每个Vertical都有一些，
人家做，
但我们缺的，
还是你能，
泡出来的一个产品，
你能有，
实际的用户订单，
对,
那说到刚刚，
你说,
不看YC的原因，
是因为，
你觉得，
头的项目比较选，
那有没有什么，
渠道是，
你觉得，
他们的一些，
我的项目是，
让你觉得比较，
靠谱,
或者让你比较感兴趣，
这个需要你自己，
在硅谱的一些人脉机类，
对,
第二点，
我觉得是在于，
一些,
一个潜带的方向，
是一个AI-native SaaS,。
大家会认为，
SaaS完了,
我其实我觉得不会，
只不过，
未来的SaaS，
会另外一种形式，
去存在，
我曾经感觉，
2024年的时候，
这样,
很多人，
做的东西，
会跟Microsoft,。
会跟Softforce,。
它没有一些overlap，
但,
如果,
他们也加了AI，
你这个，
根本就没有法，
跟他们打，
但现在问题，
就是,
最高现在，
我们的软件，
还是被这么压着，
这些,
该开发出来，
真正的AI agent，
这些软件公司，
其实并没有开玩，
得很好，
这其中一个原因，
就是,
我自己有体验过，
这种软件公司，
它本身的，
一个组织形态，
它其实不太适合，
加AI这个时代，
去管理，
它还是延续着，
一个传统的，
做SaaS的,
我觉得，
这是一个非常大的，
一个壁柄，
大公司，
最重要的，
不是你能吸引，
这个行业，
具体有多少个人才，
最重要的，
还是在于，
你整个组织架构，
是否能，
炒着同样的，
一个方向去前进，
我现在，
认为,
其实最快的方式，
莫,
可能,
可我只说，
就是,
做一个AI native的，
一个相关，
就是打破了，
原来,
它这个传统SaaS，
的这个内部组织结构，
能领导一去，
复化一个，
AI native of the SaaS,。
你可以做一个AI native of the，
Microsoft Sentinel,。
或是SaaS Force,。
这种AI customer agent,。
我觉得，
这样的速度，
起来的速度，
会更快，
但是在获取，
客源的时候，
可能,
会是一个，
比较大的一个难题，
因为,
你毕竟是，
从领导一个start up，
但是我相信，
这个点，
应该,
是一个，
未来的一个方向，
我们,
不能把所有的Bath，
我觉得，
这个进展，
是一个，
相对来说，
比较慢的过程，
从领导，
去做一个，
AI native SaaS,。
可能,
会是一个，
非常好的一个，
方向。
这样一个方向，
我觉得，
最近,
一直都很火的，
像这种，
Physical AI,。
我觉得，
快来讲，
还是一个理论节点，
或者说，
它没有人们，
预想的，
可以,
快速地，
进入到，
大家的日常生活当中，
前提,
如果没有一个，
好的一个，
数据员，
丰富,
多量的数据员，
的,
机器人的模式，
就是很大的训练，
或者说，
你训练得不够，
发话,
你只是在，
特定的情况下，
比如说，
像中国的春晚，
可以把一些，
事情做得，
非常的完美，
但是,
你要换一个环节，
换一个灯光，
换一个地板，
换几个人，
而且就是，
很难去，
skill out 这件事情，
所以我觉得，
Physical AI,。
非常长的，
一个发来周期的，
赞同了，
我感觉，
从我们，
刚开始认识那会儿，
就很多人，
是被A的能力，
给震撼到，
都觉得，
我必须要做点什么，
但是,
到现在，
二六年，
改变,
慢慢地回到，
这种商业的城市，
得找一个具体的人，
帮他解决，
一个具体的问题，
让他去付钱，
就变成了，
新的生产工具，
就像你刚刚说，
那个,
对的,
新的soft 不一样，
是的,
现在大家已经，
从那个model first,。
转换成一个problem first，
我认为，
这才是一个，
产品的一个核心逻辑，
无论你是一个互联网，
还是AI的时代，
永远不是为了，
去加入一个fancy的，
科技,
而去做这件事情，
你还是要抓住，
本质的一个，
核心的需求，
再加上思考，
你这个产品，
为什么一定要，
加这个feature，
你所希望的，
那种fancy的feature,。
它可能，
在,
消费者原理，
它就是一个，
流存率很低的，
人们大家审评，
不高用的一个东西，
对的,
像刚刚说，
其实很多这种，
AI,
MateF的公司，
它这种出售公司，
它虽然组织架构很轻，
产品迭代也很快，
但是其实，
他们对单性的，
反而不是传统这些，
soft公司,
而是,
这些模型厂商，
对的,
因为,
模型一升级，
可能你的产品，
就会有，
被吃掉这种风险，
这个担心，
在现在的，
硅谱同学者中，
还是真是存在了吗？
真是存在的，
而且真是，
已经被证实了，
问题,
刚才提到的，
大家已经默认，
重新能力，
一定会越来越强，
你跟模型离得越近，
其实你被吞噬的，
可能性就会越大，
所以,
大家还是在，
去fake out,。
怎么去，
view up,。
自己的一个优势，
比如说，
像你的产品，
如何去做一个，
好的分发，
抓住用户的需求，
如何跟用户的，
然后相匹配，
甚至说，
有一些传统的idea，
怎么去建立你，
产品的一些brand，
然后如何去，
经由你的community，
这些事情，
都,
现在,
依旧很重要，
尤其像，
这种community,。
这种brand,。
对于2C类的产品，
我觉得还是蛮重要的。
对吧,
好,
那我们到最后一趴，
就,
经纪了这三年之后，
你自己对AI，
最明显的判断，
有没有什么发生变化，
比如说，
你不再相信什么了，
或者说，
更相信什么了？
我其实，
在三年之前，
我还是认为model first，
虽然我刚才说，
我认为，
你的模型能力，
够强,
问题居然，
居然解决，
但其实不是，
它还是，
设计到很多产品，
设计组织流程，
用户行为的这种问题，
尤其像2C端，
我觉得2C端，
现在最大的问题，
就是用户的行为问题，
第二点，
还是,
我认为AI的cost，
很重要，
我之前，
其实有在想，
因为我之前要怀疑的一点，
就是,
到底AI能发展到，
什么样的一个程度？
我当时是没有办法预测的，
就没有办法预测这个cost，
而现在来看，
它cost的确实很重要，
甚至说，
因为,
芯片,
它需要更多的，
这种供应商，
从而带货了，
非常多的行业，
在股市场，
对大家可以看得到，
所以,
我认为，
接下来，
虽然偷困会变得，
越来越便宜，
但是,
你训练模型，
然后部署模型，
这一系列的成本，
我认为，
是非常重要的一个point，
我曾经以为，
这种不是那么的重要，
而且,
越重要，
我觉得，
第三点，
就我刚才所说的，
勇敢地去做，
你的AI native SaaS,。
不要总是，
以这样，
这种传统 SaaS 工资，
会带来一些不同，
我曾经真的，
很多次，
我看到一些项目，
都会反问，
就说,
你觉得这个大公司，
要做这个AI，
不也是很快，
把你给干掉吗？
是,
要不然我们没有Manus，
Manus,
它就是这种，
办公的用品，
办公的这种，
三件套架上的AI，
你的PPT,
你的Sarmory,。
你的各种的，
架上的AI，
这件事情，
最该做出来，
就是Microsoft,。
但是,
它没有做出来，
可以感觉到，
一些新的共识，
也在慢慢地产生，
比如说，
你刚刚说的，
Coken 的Coffee,。
还有一些基建，
以及一些，
创业的共识，
这是我，
比较相信吧，
现在,
对,
感谢您收听本期，
AI Odyssey 的播客,。
如果您喜欢今天的内容，
请分享给您的朋友，
同时也欢迎您，
在强硬的播客平台上，
留下宝贵的意见和反馈，
我们将继续为您带来，
更多有趣的话题，
和嘉宾敬请期待，
再次感谢您的收听，
我们下期节目再见。